and did you have full ownership of your
own of your own character how did that
work out with
because it's you create it within the
WWF yeah right so was there Partnerships
in it and stuff like that
you ready for this story maybe if it's
uncomfortable no no it's way cool okay
it's just really a little twister
I own everything I own whole code my own
whole company on holster congratulations
I want a few few guys that own their
name and the rights and the trademarks
and licenses I own everything yeah
so when I first the name I was wrestling
I had several names Super Destroyer
Terry Boulder Sterling golden Terry the
whole Boulder different Sterling golden
sounds no offense I know it's you but
yeah I don't love that one I know well
that was a guy named Jim Barnett who's a
very nice man yes Jim Barnett was cool
yeah he was cool
you know okay it's a little light in the
loafers but he's a good guy hey yeah
loved him to death
but
[Laughter]
anyway yeah so anyway I went through all
these different things and finally when
I quit and I was working on the docs
I'll Never Wrestle again I'm done I'm
you know five or six times I've quit I'm
over this crap
I get a call from Vince McMahon and a
couple local wrestlers Jack and Jerry
Briscoe who are here in Florida Jack was
an NCAA Champion World Heavyweight
Champion wrestlers yeah they said you
know Vince McMahon
this is perfect for you this is Madison
Square Garden this is all the really big
wrestlers go
and they kept pounding on me pounding on
me I said okay well I'll go up there but
I'm not taking my wrestling stuff with
me like
what kind of a horse's ass is that
so I fly up there and they had just got
rid of Superstar Billy Graham because
he'd kind of like they had some problems
with him
as soon as soon as I walked in I mean I
was jacked I was all yoked something I
was like 330 pounds I was working on the
docks running game on the doc's arm
wrestling everybody it's tough so I walk
up there in the whole buildings I can't
slid through the building I didn't know
how to get in correctly so I had to cut
through the crowd for about 20 or 30
feet and the whole building started on
superstar superstar I thought I was
Billy Graham uh I had a tie-dye tank top
on I didn't even think about it and
Vince McMahon senior goes don't you ever
wear that tie-dye in here yeah I guess
he just had a blowout with Billy Graham
so anyway I met with him and
and he talks about what they wanted to
pay me you know because I I just get
tired of getting screwed over and they
talked about getting me a place to live
and having a guy travel with me just
with the one of the worst decisions ever
made that hooked me up with one of the
biggest con men ever really yeah I don't
know if you know who Atlanta was yeah
Captain Lou Albano his partner Tony
altamore they were the Sicilians Tag
Team Champions I remember Tony okay well
Tony was
the biggest car you ever met he taught
me everything how to slip and fall in a
grocery store and we'll have two three
grand how to do everything you know yeah
so it just it was horrible to put me
with him but smart me up to what the
world's all about
so anyway as I'm talking he goes you
know what I want you to be Hulk Hogan I
said well what does Hulk Hogan mean it
goes like that I haven't posted for the
Polish Americans Bruno San Martino for
the Italian Americans Chief Jay
Strongbow for the Native American Indian
Americans
and I want you to be Hulk Hogan for the
Irish Americans here's two bottles of
red dye I want your hair red
and you know and they put me with Fred
blassie
and I told Fred I said brother I'm going
bald headed as it is if I put this red
Donna here the party's over so if dog
goes down the toilet oh my God he's
gonna fire us I could care less and they
didn't fire me yeah but that's how I get
the name right Hulk Hogan represents the
Irish Americans dang and Vince gave you
the name
so now Vince died the Irish goodbye that
could have been your finishing move ooh
strong brother I like that sorry that
would have been really good not trying
to tell you what to do but it could have
been neat because but what you did work
great yeah
so anyway Vince dies Vince the sun takes
over and right when this Hulk Hogan
thing takes off we get a call from
Marvel Comics
you're infringing on Mark
reasonably similar Lou ferrigno's
character the with the cartoon character
Incredible in the magazine is before the
TV series right you know you're in
friends you got our Mark we're gonna sue
you put you in litigation so
we went ahead and and let them have the
name
didn't license the name but they only
had I only had to pay him one tenth of
one percent oh wow so out of a dollar if
I got a penny I had I only had to pay
him one tenth of a penny and that went
from 85 to 25 20 years
fast forward to 2005.
it's over you know and I can now I can't
use Hulk Hogan in there I'm red hot in
2005 man I'm still jamming so into my
attorneys I don't give a damn what deal
you make you're going to make that deal
because I need the name so what happened
was we went and I get a one-year
extension
I had to PM 30 of everything I made
movies TV wrestling they got 30 of
everything
but
if they decided to sell the name they
had to give me first shot at it they
couldn't you know sell the name or do
anything you know right at a fair market
value so all of a sudden Marvel Comics
gets in a fest with a WWE about
intellectual properties that they can't
re-air old Hulk Hogan matches which
means was re-airing on this stuff they
lost Marvel Comics lost and they'll
events like uh 35 million dollars and
they made the huge mistake of including
that in the deal and they said no
instead of paying you 35 million dollars
how about if we give you the Hulk Hogan
name and I heard about it and I went you
got screwed up now because now I don't
have to pay 35 million dollars for the
name you have to sell it to me at a fair
market value which is only like 750
Grand wow yeah so I bought the name
backer and Vince wanted to buy the name
for me and went nah I think I got this
let me get this yeah I got this one wow
did that feel pretty yeah that must have
been a cool moment because then it's
almost like you own yourself yeah so I
bought the name back and I just own
everything
wow congratulations yeah it's really
hard to do in these and then yeah how
many guys you know that have that can
say that yeah
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one